pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Fonction publique en
cette semaine on vient d'en parler où se
tient le congrès annuel de l'Association
des maires de France il faut
malheureusement constater que les sujets
d'inquiétude sur le bon fonctionnement
de nos communes et sur leur situations
financières sont bien réelles c'est
pourquoi je tiens à revenir sur l'un des
engagements pris par votre gouvernement
lors de la réforme des retraites en
effet dans le cadre de cette réforme il
a été programmé à partir de 2024 la
hausse d'un point de cotisation des
employeurs publics à la Caisse nationale
de retraite des agents des collectivités
locales dites CNRA cl selon certaines
estimations cette cette augmentation
pèsera sur les finances de nos communes
autour de 640 millions d'euros par an en
contre-partie vous vous étiez engagé à
compenser intégralement cette hausse et
cet engagement s'est traduit par
l'approbation à l'article 9 dans la loi
de finance rectificative de la sécurité
sociale en 2023 introduisant un principe
de compensation intégrale de celle-ci
dans les conditions à définir par la loi
or à ce jour aucune mesure technique n'a
été prise pour le rendre applicable plus
alarmant encore rien n'est mentionné
dans le projet de loi de finance 2024
pour les employeurs publics à la
différence du secteur privé cette hausse
étant compensée pour ces derniers par
une baisse à du concurrence des
cotisations accident du travail et
malades professionnelles or monsieur le
ministre cette précision apportée pour
le secteur privé signifie t-elle que les
engagements pris pour les employeurs
publics est reporté à plus tard et si
tel n'est pas le cas je vous demande de
nous indiquer si des modalités de mise
en œuvre de cette promesse sont bien
prévues pour
2024 pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique monsieur Guerini merci
Monsieur le merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Isabelle Floren
alors vous m'interrogez sur les
conditions de financement et la
contribution des employeurs
territoriauxx hospitaliers à la caisse
de retraite des agents des
fonctionnaires territoriaux et
hospitaliers d'abord pour vous répondre
il faut porter un regard lucide sur la
situation financière de cette caisse de
retraite elle connaît d'ors et déjà un
déficit un déficite qui va aller en
s'aggravant dans les anné à venir
principalement d'ailleurs pour des
raisons de démographie il y avait pour
la fonction publique hospitalière et
territoriale quatre fonctionnaires actif
pour un fonctionnaire retraité dans les
années 90 c'est
1,55 aujourd'hui ça sera à peine plus de
1 à l'horizon 2030 et c'est pour ça que
il y a un déficit de 1,2 milliard
d'euros au moment où nous nous parlons
et que les perspectives financières
c'est 8 milliards d'euros de déficit à
horizon 2030 et donc c'est dans ce cadre
là que le gouvernement a annoncé la
hausse d'un point du taux de cotisation
des employeurs publics à cette caisse de
retraite mais à cette annonce le
gouvernement a ajouter un engagement et
il a été pris par madame la Première
ministre dans cette assemblée de
compensation intégrale de cette hausse
de cotisation je réitère devant vous cet
engagement aujourd'hui alors il nous
reste à fixer les modalités techniques
nous en avons discuté avec les
employeurs territoriaux a été évoqué un
transfert de taux pour réaliser cela
c'est une question que le gouvernement
prend très au sérieux puisque le
gouvernement a missionné trois
inspections l'IGF l'IGA et l'IGAS pour
une mission d'inspection qui doit rendre
sur cette question ses conclusions d'ici
la fin du mois de novembre pour que nous
puissions intégrer dans les textes
financiers la modalité de compensation
de cette hausse de taux et que cette
modalité de compensation intervienne
concomitamment à cette hausse de taux
j'ajoute que cette mission a pour
objectif de poser un diagnostic à la
demande des employeurs territoriaux et
hospitaliers et des pistes de
d'équilibrage de cette caisse de
retraite à moyen à long terme vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice nous avançons
en responsabilité mais nous avançons
aussi en transparence avec l'ensemble
des élus locaux et des employeurs
hospitaliers madame Floren
oui merci Monsieur prcision vous
comprenez que à l'heure où les communes
préparent leur budget cette information
est primordiale et qu'il faut l'avoir
dans dans les plus bref délai maintenant
donc nous attendons effectivement le
rapport pour les employeurs publics
c'est tout à fait nécessaire et utile
dans dans cette prévision
budgétaire la parole est à